[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
during the runtime of application
[Music]
[Music]
my talk was called Haiti even design and
how we design for the web how we design
for people in an inclusive and
intersectional way have fun and that the
web can do any kind of nonsense how we
can improve programming a communication
thinking better about language my
journey of chatting gears levers in my
city burning bright but not bearing out
errors and error handling and ways to be
less scared of errors 10 regrets about
node bugs that were made
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I applied for a scholarship I want to
get this experience and try to get it to
my own community reason why I attend
change camp is to experience the the
cyphers atmosphere of depth community
and I think it's the reason why taya
community is going so fast I actually
first came to this conference two years
ago on a scholarship ticket like the
next year I was kind of watching the
tool to me interacting with people on
Twitter this year I'm here as a speaker
and throughout that journey I have made
some incredible friends Jos home feel is
really the one event that brings the
whole JavaScript community together
across different frameworks across
different libraries
[Music]
me personally the thing I love about us
compass I've made friends in my
adulthood that I wouldn't have normally
made how welcoming is the community to
people from all over the world and how
they try to make it happen with
scholarships and so on that really
people feel welcomed and integrated into
the conference so no matter where you're
from what languages you speak your
access Nate Holland the organizers and
the volunteers has been so much effort
into trying to make this event as
accessible as possible for everyone that
and the fact that some killer talks Jaya
stomp brings together the people that
are making the future of JavaScript that
people that are on the standards bodies
and making the frameworks with the
people who are the future of JavaScript
with newcomers with all of the people
who are going to be the next wave of
future makers
[Music]